keeping up with the kardashians has
officially come to an end
kim kardashian took to her social media
to announce that the 20th and final
season of the show's 14-year run will
premiere early next year
the show has been the cornerstone of the
lucrative kardashian jenner family
phenomenon
the family's five sisters and mother
kris jenner will walk away with more
than two billion dollars between them
and no shortage of future earning
potential
the reality tv show only makes up a
fraction of the income for the family's
top two earners
kim kardashian west and her younger
half-sister kylie jenner
forbes estimates that kardashian west
earned 49.5 million dollars in the
months leading up to june 2020
with only 20 percent of that coming from
the show
for kylie jenner show earnings account
for less than one percent
of the 590 million dollars she earned in
the year leading up to june
the other sisters courtney chloe and
kendall
each earn millions from endeavors
outside the series
their show might be over but the
kardashian jenner family won't stop
making headlines
anytime soon
[Music]